et puis à place de la nation ce sont les
gilets jaunes qui ont appelé à un grand
rassemblement pour exiger le retrait
immédiat du passé ni terre et obtenir la
mise en place d'un grenelle du pouvoir
d'achat manifestation suivie par notre
reporter david kelly ça que l'on va
retrouver tout de suite
à mon jour des billets alors quelle est
l'ambiance
le cortège suit son cours a jusqu au
sacré coeur un millier de gilles étoiles
rassemblés dans la rue cet après midi
avec plusieurs revendications vous
l'avais dit la mise en place du grenelle
du pouvoir d'achat fer de lance de
l'occupation à des ronds-points en 2018
pour ce mouvement né il ya trois ans
maintenant et puis également dénoncé le
rejet de la classe politique des
préoccupations des français et dénoncer
la gestion de la crise sanitaire je me
trouve actuellement avec un fusil
lellouche choisi le loot une des figures
d'aidé gilet jaune faut dit merci de
répondre à nos questions on l'a vu
aujourd'hui cet après-midi grosse
mobilisation
on al impression qu à l approche des
élections présidentielles le mouvement
des gilet jaune aura son mot à dire
exactement l'important c'était de
maintenir la pression sur les
gouvernants même si on n'a plus
confiance en eux et on a le sentiment
qu'on n'est pas vraiment représenter
surtout quand on voit les débats qui
s'oriente plutôt vers la stigmatisation
des personnes comme la droite sait le
faire l'extrême droite c'est le faire
moi j'ai pas combattu trois ans dans la
rue pour à la fin entendre ce genre de
discours la préoccupation de l'ensemble
des français aujourd'hui c'est leur
quotidien c'est comment ils peuvent
gagner leur vie décemment comment ils
peuvent le dépenser pour leurs familles
et se construire un avenir pour eux et
pour les leurs donc je suis désolé les
petites bagarres politiques les
arrangements et tout ça nous voilà on
est pas sorti pour ça il faut qu'à un
moment donné ces politiques nous entende
parce que quand on règle pas les
problèmes de toutes les façons on les
retrouve devant soi et là on est
toujours là trois ans après avec une
mobilisation qu'a amené des gens de
toutes les provinces et donc les gens
ont répondu présent parce que ben on est
toujours dans les mêmes difficultés
toujours pas entendu les invisibles tout
le temps on est resté invisible
heureusement que vous êtes là parce que
sinon je vois pas comment on aurait la
parole dans les médias un peu meanstream
en ligne de mire également la gestion de
la crise sanitaire avec notamment de
l'obligation vaccinale pour pour les
soignants mais aussi celles autorisées
aux enfants ça c'est aussi l'objectif de
cet après-midi dénoncé à cette
obligation vaccinale exactement donc on
peut voir les effets les effets qui sont
pas prouvées de la vaccination on voit
des gens qui sont vaccinés et qui
pourtant attrapé la maladie du coc vide
donc ils peuvent le transmettre ou même
e être contaminé donc je vois pas en
quoi ces vaccins ont fait la preuve et
aujourd'hui on voudrait expérimenté sur
nos enfants ben non moi je suis désolé
j'estime que il faut alerter un petit
peu faut être prudent c'est la
génération qui va suivre c'est tous les
nôtres et on peut pas les mettre en
péril comme ça vacciner n'importe
comment n'importe qui au détriment de
résultats j'estime que voilà alors on
est venus là aussi pour les dénoncer
parce que ce gouvernement il est en roue
libre et on a le sentiment que c'est
même plus le gouvernement français qui
décide on a l'impression que c'est
l'europe qui décide alors quand on
entend emmanuel macron qui a coulé ce
pays qui a endetté ce pays qui a jamais
pris les bonnes mesures qui a jamais
répondu depuis trois ans à ces citoyens
qui aujourd'hui espèrent prendre la
présidence parce qu'on sait très bien il
veut prendre la présidence de l'europe
parce qu'en france quelque part il est
grillé les études de sondages on n'a pas
confiance et on sait très bien que ce
gars là bas pour nous il a endetté la
france et il l'a jamais valorisé donc il
a jamais eu un mot pour les citoyens qui
voudraient prendre quoi l'europe
gouverner encore plus largement pour lui
c'est quoi c'est juste un carriériste
non on a on attend que les gouvernants
qui soit à la tête qu'on est élu prenne
soin des gens répondent aux attentes des
gens et
soin protecteur de la des civils soit
protecteur de la population encore plus
des enfants j'estime que voilà ça nous
tient à coeur nous on est prêt à se
sacrifier mais pas nos enfants si
beaucoup posé les loups d'avoir répondu
à nos questions là comme vous pouvez le
voir sur des images de julien guitare un
important dispositif de sécurité a été
mis en place tout autour du cortège le
préfet didier lallement positif aux
copies de 19 et contre un isolement gère
à distance ses troupes il a renforcé les
effectifs matériels et humains pour ce
rassemblement voilà vous l'aurez compris
un comme l a dit fawzi lellouche le
mouvement des îles et jaune espère
s'inscrire dans la durée pour pouvoir
peser dans la balance lors des
prochaines élections présidentielles et
offrir voilà un petit pétard qui vient
d'exploser près près de nous et offrir
une saison 3 des gilets jaunes mémorable
merci david à on se retrouve tout à
l'heure